Kate Middleton is shutting down claims
about her duties within the royal family
and her relationship with brother and
sister-in-law Prince Harry and Meghan
Marvel working together as family do you
ever have disagreements about things in
a rare move Kensington Palace released a
statement on Wednesday refuting Tattler
magazines recent cover story Catherine
the Great the statement reads quote this
story contains a swath of inaccuracies
and false misrepresentations which were
not put to Kensington Palace prior to
publication meanwhile a spokesperson
from Tattler tells ET that their
editor-in-chief stands behind anna
pastor Nick's reporting and her sources
adding that the palace knew they were
running the cover months ago and were
asked to work together on it Tattler
claims the fact they are denying they
ever knew is categorically false
in short the article praises Kate for
her hard work but at the expense of
Harry and Meghan who stepped down as
senior members of the royal family on
March 31st a few quotes from the article
read in part Kate is furious about the
larger workload she feels exhausted and
trapped and she's working as hard as a
top CEO who has to be wheeled out all
the time without the benefits of
boundaries and plenty of holidays and
get this the article even makes claims
about Kate's mom Carole Middleton
calling her quote the mummy Prince
William always wanted the story also
alleges that Kate and William had a
falling-out with their friends Rose
Hanbury and her husband over roses
apparent closeness to William we're
still together for the rest of our lives
this is true togetherness yeah as for
Kate's relationship with Harry and Megan
Tattler sites a friend who claims that
Kate never pulled Megan under her wing
to show her the ropes adding that
Catherine and William were very
circumspect from the beginning about
Megan which hurt and incensed Harry what
we do know is that the Cambridge's have
continued to work during the global
coronavirus pandemic William and Kate
really to be the frontline Royals in
this national emergency
the couple has continued to reach out to
charities and organizations around
Britain via zoom all while trying to
home-school and entertain their three
young children
George Charlotte and Louie something
Kate recently opened up about during a
rare interview with Britain's ITV's it's
really it is difficult it's hard to
explain to you know five and a six
eighty seven year olds what's going on
but but no the schools being great and
supporting them as well